Now let's briefly talk optical disks. An optical disk
is very similar to a hard disk in that
it has a platter that rotates and we store
the bits on the surface of the disk. The
difference is that, instead of there being a head
that needs to be placed very close to the
disk surface, we can shoot a laser to the
surface and the reflection from the material here will
tell us whether we have a zero or a one. But many of the other properties of
the optical disks are very similar to hard disks.
They have tracks and so on. Unlike hard drives
that tends to be closed units, so you don't
just insert a new hard drive into the machine,
and you don't carry one with you usually, optical
drives don't need the laser to get that close
to the surface so the smudges or dust are less of a problem for it. Basically if
there is a speck of dust here, it doesn't
scratch the laser as it rotates, but a speck
of dust will scratch the magnetic head as
it rotates and probably glue itself to the head
and then the head no longer works. So hard
drives have much more of a problem with dirt,
so they need to be an enclosed case. Because
optical disks suffer less from this problem, we often see
them in the form of CDs and DVDs that
we can carry around and even though they get dirty,
we can still read data from them. But as
a result of them being portable, they need to be
standardized so that we can put a CD or
a DVD into any drive that we want. And this
standardization helps improve portability and their usefulness, but
it limits the rate of improvement, because the
technology improves but then that technology needs to
make it through a standards process, where companies
agree that something will be a standard and
only then make it into products. So really,
the technology can improve relatively rapidly. But we
don't see any of that progress until a new
standard is decided on at which point products
are released. In contrast, with hard drives, the whole
enclosure needs to obey some standards about how
to connect to the rest of the computer, but
what happens inside the enclosure can be the
latest and greatest technology in magnetic disks. So usually
optical disks are used for pretty much carrying
the data around, storing music, movies and so on.